one of the questions that we regularly
ask each other people call in they ask
me i ask producer pat yeah we're regular
i ask guests
are these
lunatic conspiracy theorists
particularly when it comes to the
election the election fraud alleged of
2020
do they really believe it or is it just
something they say to show that they're
on the team so when we see a poll that a
while ago said oh 57 percent of trump
voters believe trump won even though he
didn't
we asked the question
do they literally believe trump won or
do they see saying trump won as how they
signal that they're on trump's team
it could be one the other could be a
combination of the two
when it comes to my pillow ceo mike
lindell we now have a leaked test text
message that tells us he's a true
believer we see pillow come out and say
all these things oh it's the machines
and remember he wanted to sue all
machines we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines right and
we wonder could this guy possibly be for
real well it turns out that on december
20th of 2020 pillow texted trump chief
of staff mike lindell the text message
is longer than a cvs receipt so we're
going to look at it in pieces but the
takeaway is
he really is a believer look at what he
this is not something he said publicly
this is a private text message to mark
meadows and mike pillow believes it all
it reads
hey mark i felt i was supposed to text
you this message you being a man
of faith and on the front line of the
decisions that are going to be
historical i guess he means historic i
would ask that you pray for wisdom and
discernment from god you are one of the
people the president trusts the most
that being said i want to add my input
everything sydney he's referring to
sydney powell trump's i guess lawyer at
the time everything sydney has said is
true we have the machines and everything
we already have proves the president won
by millions of votes i have read and not
validated yet that you and others talked
him out of seizing them if true i prayed
as part of a bigger plan this is pillow
wanting the voting machines to be seized
by trump i am grateful that on the night
of the election the algorithms of the
corrupt machines broke and they realized
our president would win in spite of the
historical fraud i look for deviations
every day in my business when i find one
i investigate relentlessly until i know
why it happened and how it happened this
is my gift from god that has made my
business so successful
he's a he's a real believer
he is completely out of his mind he goes
on to write to mark meadows from 11 15
pm on the night of the election i have
spent all my time running impossible
deviations and numbers from this
election
what i also was blessed to be able to
get info and help sydney lin general
flynn
and everyone else out there gathering
all the massive evidence i have been
sickened by politicians especially
republican judges the media not wanting
to see the truth no matter what the
truth would be this is the biggest
cover-up of one of the worst crimes in
history i have spent over a million
dollars to help uncover this fraud and
use my platform so people can get the
word not give up not to give up
the people on both sides have to see the
truth and when they do there will be no
civil war people including politicians
are fearing the only thing any of us
should fear is fear of the lord every
person on this planet needs to know the
truth and see the evidence mark
god has his hand in all of this and has
put you on the front line i will
continue praying for you to have great
wisdom and discernment blessings mike
and uh mark meadows responded thanks
brother
pray for a miracle
he
really believes it and the reason we
care about this is that it's arguably
harder to deal with people who really
believe it with people who only say it
you merely have to convince them it's no
longer in their interest to say it but
they already didn't believe it so it's
much simpler and more straightforward
when you have a real believer like this
it is much more difficult to disabuse
them of these beliefs and to deprogram
them and that's obviously what we're
coming up against right now the the kind
of silliest part is where he sees that
there are some impossible deviations
like as if pillow has any idea how
statistics work or any idea how to apply
them in the real world but more
importantly
we still haven't actually seen any of
the data that this is supposedly based
on and that's maybe the wackiest thing
which is going all the way back to the
beginning pillow has insisted we have
machines we have data we have uh all we
have all of it we've run statistical
analysis okay well when are you going to
show us the data oh i'll show it to you
at my symposium or my symposium as he
would call it and then he didn't show
anything and then it's been a year
almost a year and a half now if you have
the data it would be great for you to
show it it's always a week away from
coming out
my guess is they don't have it but if
these text messages prove anything it's
that he really believes this and i think
it's safe to believe
at least some portion of other
republicans truly believe it as well
sure some of them just say it yeah trump
won trump won i believe that trump won
if trump stopped saying it they would
stop saying it too
but mike lindell
truly genuinely and sincerely seems to
believe this fairy tale and that makes
it all the more difficult to deal with
we'll have the text message up on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video